il
cher journal je me suis fait cambrioler
alors que je venais tout juste
d'emménager
je suis sorti promener mon chien en
laissant les clefs sur la porte d'entrée
et quand je suis revenu tout avait
disparu sauf ceux dont je n'ai pas
besoin
évidemment je me sens complètement
déconnecté normalement une digital detox
tu choisis quand tu t'y mets comme c'est
la même histoire
alors il paraît que ça va m'aider à me
retrouver mais bon prison pour l'instant
j'en suis au stade où la seule chose qui
m'apaise ray serait de regarder freine
sur ma télé en passant d'un réseau à un
autre sur mon smartphone pour me
récompenser d'avoir travaillé sur mon
ordi toute la journée
j'avais tas de choses à terminer mais
j'ai rien pour procrastiner c'est moins
évident que ça en a l'air de ne pas
faire ce qu'on a à faire quand on a rien
d'autre à faire je suis complètement
paumé j'ai juste la carte du grand
canyon et bah je sais pas comment y
aller j'ai besoin d'un gps pour aller
d'un point a à un point b alors le nord
norel le nord mais là je ne peut
prévenir personne que je suis un
joignable et si quelqu'un m'appelle et
ben je ne peux même plus attendre que la
sonnerie s'arrête pour continuer à lire
les commentaires d'une publication
inintéressante
c'est marrant je n'ai jamais vu autant
de choses à prendre en photo que depuis
que je ne peux plus rien publié
c'est dommage je pense que j'aurais pu
gagner pas mal d'abonnés sur ça me donne
envie de faire une story pour dire que
j'ai quitté les réseaux sociaux j'espère
qu'on va pas m'oublier chargé je vous
remercie mr